Hi, my name is Ingrid Carlqvist, I am
here today with Raymond Ibrahim and
we're going to talk about the downfall
of the Western civilization. Not just
that, but also
Europe as a society. You've written a
lot about Islam, the danger of Islam,
but you also really talk a lot about
masculinity and I think it's very
interesting to see what that
intersection is cuz there is a link, but
nobody really talks about it yet.
>> Yeah. I've always said that men are
under attack and either they're denied
that they exist how with the woke
ideology cuz gender is a spectrum. Same
is of course for women. So, a lot of men
don't know how to be men anymore.
>> Mhm.
Uh and on the other hand, you have of
course the Andrew Tates of the world
that are portraying a very toxic way of
how a man should be.
Either way, we're doomed.
There was this documentary that I saw.
It was inside the manosphere. It's a big
topic right now.
What do you think of the manosphere?
Um I think
I think the whole topic of masculinity
and femininity the closer something is
to human nature, the more people are
instinctively prone to just do it and
not think or talk about it. So, I think
historically, very few people would have
sat and told you or even thought about
what masculinity or femininity is simply
because they were it naturally. The
reason it's a problem now is um for a
number of of outside forces take people
when they're young, boys and girls
educate them, indoctrinate them into all
these ideas that now have that are
inherently against and antagonistic to
masculinity and femininity. In fact, we
can't have this conversation without
talking about both, masculinity and
femininity because it's the same assault
really on different poles of the same
topic. So, I think no one historically
would have even
had any of these these confusions that
we have, which itself underscores the
fact that these are manufactured and not
really organic things. They're just
something that
you know, we can give them their certain
names. We can of course call it now it's
toxic masculinity. And that word itself
we can get into, but you know, you
mentioned what I've been writing about
and Islam and all that and the reason it
actually comes up. I never sat and
thought about you know, it's important
to write about masculinity. My whole
topic was essentially historical and
Islam.
And but while I did that, it became very
clear especially in
comparison or juxtaposition to today's
Western man that something has
dramatically changed. So this book we
were talking about uh Defenders of the
West
uh the Christian heroes who stood
against Islam in the introduction. I
talk about exactly this. I say how come
back when Europe was actually much
weaker than it is today and it was
historically against Islam.
These men who were sometimes kings and
nobles or just peasants fought to the
death just to preserve their way of life
whereas today um
Europe is powerful and it's bringing
Muslims in and it's falling down before
them and it's crying. So the So the
reason why that is is these men had
something to fight for and they believed
in themselves and they didn't have all
these external forces that emasculated
them whereas our society really is in
many ways very nihilistic. You can call
it whatever you want and it's very
emasculating um to men and frankly
there's nothing to fight and die for.
Well, you know, what you mentioned I
think is very important. Writers know
masculinity without femininity. We need
to live together in harmony. And I
wanted really talk about what a positive
example is for men because that's what
needs to be given more attention. That
book particularly got a big interest uh
because I think there's a need to
understand that what is a healthy
example. Can you give one person that
you wrote about that you personally find
very inspiring and what is it that
modern young men that are watching this
can take away from that book and from
the examples being described there.
>> So, the book as I mentioned has to do
with various men, European Christians,
you know, from the high time of the war
with Islam, which is around the 12th
century and up until let's say the 15th,
16th century. And I just found various I
picked eight men. So, it's really eight
mini biographies. And honestly, each one
of them, if you look at their lives and
what they did,
some of them again there were kings,
there were emperors, there was for
example, Louis Saint Louis of France,
okay, who you know, I think Louis the
9th.
>> If you look at his whole life, he could
have just lived in France. He was at a
point when France was at its richest
actually and best organized, but twice
he went on crusade, twice he suffered,
his children died and he finally died.
Okay, so that is a testimony to a sort
of
very masculine piety, okay, which is
completely missing today. But there's
other men that we find here, for
example, John Hunyadi, speaking of
Hungary. They have their own host of
heroes. I think what men today can take
is and why this book resonates very much
with men in the West is because they see
that there's actually there were men who
who can A be Christian and B be
militant. And I think that's another
whole issue which I discuss, which I
I've coined doormat Christianity. What
do you mean with doormat Christianity?
What I mean by that is the dominant form
of Christianity in the West for
centuries now has been basically this
idea that begins and ends with if you're
Christian, you have to act like a
doormat, which means you you lay down,
you welcome, you don't judge, you don't
become confrontational, you never say
anything, you just your job is to shut
up and lay down and then you can pat
yourself in the back saying I'm a good
virtuous person. It's of course very
easy to do this as well.
>> It's suicidal, but it's also the easy
way out. It's not it's not it's not easy
to be confrontational, it's not easy to
be even judgmental in a correct way. So,
I think that idea has really taken hold
of Christianity and because of that men,
especially men, but women too, don't
feel like they have the right as
Christians to ever resist anything,
certainly not physically. You can't
fight. But, if you look at these men,
they were way more pious than today's
Christians, because they died for their
faith. And at the same time, they had no
problem with violence. And this is a
whole other thing we can talk about just
war theory, which is very important,
which has been also lost amongst
modern-day Christians. So, in short
>> are watching it and don't know what do
you mean with the just war theory? So,
just war theory is how the the
Christians historically
um justified warfare. Okay? So, what
what is just? Can we even have war? It
seems today that a lot of Christians
just think that they can never engage in
violence whatsoever.
But, Christians historically, going back
to St. Augustine and biblical verses,
con- concluded that yes, you can be a
good Christian and you can still engage
in war and you can even kill people.
Okay? And uh and uh we If you are and we
can get into biblical verses that even
justify that.
>> Please give me an example of a biblical
verse that justifies it.
>> Okay. So, the Old Testament, what we
call the Old Testament, is full of
verses where God is a man of war. He's
presented as that, but most, I think,
Christians understand that, but they
argue that the New Testament doesn't
have anything. So, let's talk about the
New Testament. So, the New Testament,
for example, a lot of it is implicit,
which is not necessarily that Jesus
says, "Go wage war." But, it's based on
the nature of the circumstance. It's
Church fathers, not me, have said this
means that. So, one of the primary
examples is when the Centurion comes to
Jesus and says um "Heal my servant."
And long story short, Jesus agrees,
heals him, and then the man leaves. And
now, when Jesus usually performs a
miracle, the almost every time what he
says to the person is repent. Go change
your evil ways, right? He tells the
adulterous woman, for example, and
everyone else, but they've noted that he
didn't say that to the Centurion. Now,
this man was in charge
of a hundred unit Roman army. He had
blood on his hands. He's killed. Jesus
did not say, "Now that I've done this,
go and repent." Instead, Jesus used him
as a model of faith. Okay? Same thing
with John the Baptist. There's There's
that verse where he's baptizing and
people come to him and ask him various
questions and he tells him repent,
repent. And then soldiers come to him
and he tells them repent by being
content with your wage. Doesn't say
leave the army. Okay? So, things like
that and there's many more church
fathers and ecclesiastical synods all
agreed that warfare is legitimate if
it's just, not for conquest, if it's in
defense, for example. Speaking of
fathers, you're a father yourself. You
raised two healthy boys that are strong
and I think with that you set an example
of masculinity, what is what it means to
be a man.
I wonder what what did How did you do
that? How did you try to raise them as
good, strong, healthy men that are
comfortable in their own identity, in
their own nature? And I know that you're
Coptic Orthodox and how far did your
faith play a role in that? Uh these are
good questions. Um
I didn't have a a a you know, I didn't
have a written out plan when they were
born. It was again, it was very organic,
it was very natural. And um
I just what I didn't do or what I was
very cognizant of is I already knew
society at large is going to do
everything to emasculate them. Yes. So,
I I tried to make sure that they were
also exposed to a form of
hypermasculinity in the person of
myself. Not
He's so humble, isn't he?
No, no. I made sure they were exposed.
Not as it's hypermasculinity, not
necessarily me, but just the boy things.
Okay? You know, and things that they
know So, he was fighting with them or
that and you know, all sorts of things
that were
you know, a few decades ago would have
been considered absolutely normal,
whereas today some people might bristle
a little because, you know. So, what I
tried to do is, you know, I would have
been happy if they were at five from one
to 10, but because society's at 10, I
kind of
was at one in the hopes that I can drag
them to five, and I think it worked.
Okay? Um so,
but the other So, really, I would say
the number one thing I did is I tried to
shield and prevent them from being
emasculated actively by the system.
Okay?
>> Okay,
give me some more concrete examples on
that. Okay, so if they went to school
and um told me something like, "Yeah, we
learned today that uh uh homosexuality
and sexual and all that stuff is fine."
I would I would correct them.
And and but now when you ask them, and
it didn't even take much. It's almost
like they themselves understood this.
Yeah. They just needed an an adult to
say, "Yeah, your instincts are right."
That's the problem. Most kids they don't
Their instincts rebel, but no one stops
and tells them, "Yeah, you're right." I
think also that's really the appeal for
figures like Andrew Tate cuz in many
ways, I think the message in essence is
good. Men don't need justification to be
simply men, to go out to the bar and
have a beer, and have a boys' night out,
and you know, have um
be be be in in concert with their own
nature. Um so, I completely understand
you on that.
Another topic that I think you was very
interesting when we're talking about the
Crusades is that it gave some men also a
purpose, a goal. And I agree that now in
society a man, not just men, this is of
course for women equally, we have lost
any purpose in life. Nihilism is
becoming big part of the problem. After
this duration of our civilization, how
do we bring that back? And what kind of
purpose should it be? Do we need to go
back to the Crusades?
Well, we can go back to the Crusades if
they're warranted. Um
at this point, you know, the Crusades
again, as I mentioned, were a time when
Europe and the Christian world was
actually um on the defensive. They were
the ones who were being attacked. So,
the Crusades was literally needed at the
time just for preservation and you know,
righting wrongs. What's happening today
in Europe is completely self-made. This
is Europeans doing it to themselves.
Okay, this is why certain nations in
Europe which are weak and economically
weak and often times seen as
insignificant next to the big nations,
the UK, France, Germany, they don't have
the Muslim problem because they simply
said, "No, we don't we don't want it."
So, I think the
the question of do we need a new new
crusade? I think we need a new crusade
not necessarily against Islam, but a
crusade to bring back sanity and to
bring back masculinity and femininity
and that sort of thing. And if you bring
all that stuff back, the Islam thing
will itself just go away because it's
it's really a
a symptom of our own degeneracy. Yeah,
it's interesting, you know, often I've
spoken to you before when I was your
impression in Hungary. You were joking
about starting the What was it? The
crusade workout? No. Yeah, I I get a lot
of people on the YouTube channel who
talk about stuff like that. Man, one day
one day we'll get a a crusade workout
routine put together. What would a
modern crusade look like then?
A modern crusade? Well, like I said, it
doesn't have to be militants at this
point. But a crusade, I mean,
historically it was military because
that's the only way you can make change.
But today in the West, you know,
theoretically we don't need to take up
arms to make change, right? So, but you
need you need fervency, you need an
actual goal, you need actual motivation.
And I think all of that is lacking very
much intentionally so because it's just
people people have been broken down and
convinced another part of the system is
to convince them that, you know, in
materialism. Materialism not in the like
grasping covetousness, but materialist
philosophy which means like the only
thing that really exists is what we can
feel and see which is an atheistic
notion. And I think a lot of Christians
have adopted this worldview despite what
they say. And so, what's what's happened
is really all they care about and all
they focus on is just physical which is
why going back to
which is why so many Christians today
would resist the idea of violence
because that would be evil because it's
physical, but they don't understand that
morality is also real
and it's even more important than what's
physical, but they've ignored that. So,
that's why they have no morale either to
fight back. So,
it requires a complete resuscitation of
all sorts of mores. Yeah, the morality
is completely gone in society in every
level. And the positive thing is that it
does bring people back to Christianity.
Morality has left us empty looking for
meaning, looking for substance that you
cannot replace with materialism and
nihilism, but God gives that substance.
At the same time, what I also see is
that there's also a lot of young men
that are being appealed to Islam. We see
a lot of people converting to Islam and
I wonder why is Islam so appealing for
young men?
Is it the 72 virgins that they're
promised?
Um yeah, we can say that you know, and I
mean there's a sort of comical aspect to
that, but I think the the real reason
it's appealing goes back to what we're
talking about is because unlike
unlike the West and what it's done to
Christianity, Islam still maintains very
distinct gender norms. Men are men,
women are women, boys can be boys. Like
you were saying, they can go out do
their thing.
So, I think a lot of men in the West
just gravitate they find that very
appealing because the problem is they
don't realize their own religious
tradition makes room for that. And this
goes back to what I was saying, which is
in the West, people have been taught
that if you want to be a good Christian,
you're and you're a man, you essentially
have to become a woman. Okay? And that's
that's the emasculation.
Yeah, it's the feminization of
Christianity which has led to the
feminization of Christians which has
caused a lot of nominal Christians to
not reject Christianity. I don't blame
them because that's not true
Christianity and to find
something like Islam appealing because
it offers at least what would be
considered normal and healthy, which is
for a man to be a man.
Yeah, but there's I think this not a lot
of people say it is that
is um applause men to be
who they are.
Which is something I agree with. Where
we see Western men, Christian men
think it's normal to wear dresses.
That's very extreme form, but I think
it's very symbolic on how feminized
masculinity has been. At the same time,
I'm wondering what is the true link? Cuz
I feel that what you need if you want to
destroy society is that you need to
be able to manipulate and control the
men between 18, 35, 40 years old because
these are the military men that are able
to fight for their country, that are
able to protect their borders, their
families, their nation. So, if you
emasculate them, you can control a
nation. You have carte blanche to do as
you wish.
How do we get over that? How do we make
sure that men get the willing to
be strong again? Because I think a lot
of men are these days also simply don't
care. It's been indoctrinated on such a
deep level that
that in nature has been completely uh
it's gone.
Yeah. Well, these are actually very
important questions and they're all
philosophical ultimately, which is why
they're important. And I would say the
most the
the you know, the big answer to it is
that men and just Western people in
general have admit have believed that
there is no more truth. Okay, everyone
has become a relativist, which means
that we don't think there's any concrete
absolute truths. It's basically how it's
subjective. It's how it affects me, how
it affects you. I have my truth, you
have your truth. That idea has become so
corrosive and it permeates everything.
So, in this context, for example,
who's to say what a man is? Yeah, you
have your idea of a man, I have my idea.
There is no true. But if you
don't have you're not poisoned by these
toxic ideas and you're a natural person
who hasn't been indoctrinated, you know,
like I said, you know inherently and
instinctively what a man is. You know
what a woman is instinctively. And you
yourself will want to gravitate and
express it that way because it's
natural. It's aligned with the truth.
But that's my point. If you don't
believe there are truths, okay, then
then you are a relative, then you there
is nothing to fight for. Well, why
should I fight for anything? There is no
real concrete truth. So, I I know that's
an abstract kind of philosophical
answer, but I think that really gets to
the heart of it, which is Western man,
woman, need to acknowledge that there
are inherent transcendent metaphysical
truths above and beyond the material
world. And if we do that, then I think
and we cling to it,
then everything falls into place. So, a
perfect example is this gender sexual
confusion. Okay? Uh to most people,
Muslims, but not just Muslims, everyone
outside the West, there's two genders.
There is men, there is women. Okay? And
anatomically, their parts fit and life
comes out of it. Okay? That's the end of
it.
So, for us in the West to find this as
too simple and you know, and we need to
nuance it and we have to add a million
different genders and all that, that's
the problem. That's the kind of
mentality which has said there's no
truth. I just told you what the truth
is, which everyone believes cuz it's
true. They've said there's no more truth
and they're confused and now they don't
know how to be men, they don't know how
to be women, they have nothing to fight
for, and etc. etc. Yeah, I mean, as a
human being, there's just I mean, we're
binary. You're man or you're female.
We're not oysters. We're not shifting
genders.
Oysters? Yeah, oysters. I always say
that women need to learn how to be women
again.
As I said, there is a balance and it's
it's a fundament of society that
um we restore that balance again.
It's a principle on how societies are
built. We've been talking about
masculinity, how do we restore
femininity?
Well, actually, I would like to ask you
that, you being a representative woman.
What are your thoughts pray tell? Well,
first and foremost, you know, and I talk
from my personal experience with growing
up. I was really ashamed I was really I
was being taught that it's a shameful
thing to want to become a mother,
especially when I went to
>> Housewife or Exactly. Especially in
university was told that, you know, if
you want to have children before the age
of 30, it's a low-class thing to do.
You're an educated woman. So, you should
achieve to have a career and that's what
>> is in Netherlands?
>> This is in the Netherlands. I grew up in
a very liberal country. At the same
time, I am I am very proudly Dutch, but
I'm also Moldavian, you know, that's my
roots. And in Moldova, women are more
traditional, more conservative, and
I would say more feminine. So, even in
high school, I would wear heels and
dresses and I was I was being bullied
because of that. I didn't really fit in
and I had a very hard time
finding my way in that. And then when I
moved to Brussels, I uh it got even
worse and then I lost my true identity.
So,
to come back to your question.
>> your hair and paint it blue or anything
like that?
>> All the colors of the rainbow.
I didn't go blonde, but I will never try
that again. No, first and foremost, we
need to stop girls wanting to be girls.
And you know what? A lot of this shame
comes from other women. I was shamed by
other women for wearing makeup. It
didn't come from men. So, women need to
applaud other women to be feminine
again. And then we need to stop with
this notion that if you want to take
care of yourself, it's you're you're
you're very look at me.
Because why? Femininity starts with how
you feel. And if you feel good about
yourself, you get in that feminine
nature. That's how you restore it again.
It's the small things. We can talk about
it in a very abstract way. We can talk
it about it in a policy way because it
these things matter, but it starts with
the individual as well. How we raise
girls, that we say that it's okay if you
want to become a mother, that your
worth is not
linked to your productivity in work.
Because mothers are full-time CEOs. And
did so much more edifying, fulfilling
job, actually, I think.
>> But also restore beauty again. I want
all women to be I love it when I see a
girl dressed up in heels and you can
tell she put a lot of effort into her
outfit. It's beautiful. We need to
restore beauty in society. That's That's
a godly thing to have on
uh in our worlds. So, what I find
interesting about what you said is how
much it complements what I said about
men. So, look at your own personal
experiences. In Romania, it seemed like
what you're describing was Moldova,
sorry.
Good point. Um
Uh over there you described how And it
would be the same in Romania and a lot
of countries in that region.
>> you know, I think it's an Eastern
European thing.
>> And um basically more traditional
mentality of what a woman is and what a
man is. But it's interesting because
when you went to the West, all of a
sudden that was no longer acceptable.
And notice how you felt of the peer
pressure in your youth. So, you know, we
were talking about my kids and kids in
general. That's That's what you have to
guard against. They're going to be at at
their most impressionable time
feeling natural, feeling like they want
to be boys and men or women, in your
case.
And all the pressure comes on to tell
you no, no. And like you said, it's from
women for you. And from them it's going
to be from emasculated men who are
teachers and and whatnot. So, it's the
same sort of thing. And um you know, and
this is also why, you know, just like
it's something in the West because your
point about Moldovia
is really telling to me. And also these
are the countries that don't have a
problem with Islam, okay? Because they
also are realists. They don't invite
Muslims in masses. So, you can clearly
see that whether we're talking about
Muslim migration or the war on the
sexes, there's just something really
wrong in the West. Yeah, and it goes
beyond that, you know, one point we I
spoke about it maybe in a superficial
way, but what I think Islam is doing
better compared to Christianity and
especially how it's being applied in the
West. Well, they're having babies.
They're having babies, but also marriage
because you need to have babies within
marriage. I don't know what it's like in
Egypt, in your country, but in
Netherlands the average age to get
married is like after 30, you know. A
lot of men I think it's time to settle
down when they're In the Middle East by
the by the time a woman's in her
mid-30s, she probably has six, seven
children. Exactly. She's maybe on her
way to become a grandmother.
And happy about it, too. Here I meet
women who are like 60 and they're like,
"I don't want to be a grandmother." And
it's like But that's such a You know, I
really feel for it. That's my biggest
fear to be 50 and motherless. Sometimes
it's not an option. Sometimes you just
haven't found a right partner, but I
think also a lot of women in the West
think they first need to make a career
and then settle down. But see, this is
this is another important point. The
reason people in the West are not
getting married I I think a lot of them
want to and they can't find the right
partner. The reason they can't find the
right partner goes back to what we're
talking about because
if you're a natural healthy woman and
the pool of men, you know, 80% of them
have been emasculated, you don't want
any of that. And if you're a natural man
and the pool of women 80% have been
feminists, you know, you don't want any
part of that and and even if you try to
work it out and it doesn't if it falls
apart and people, you know, can't get
along. So, you can see how these ideas
have, you know, created much mischief
amongst men and women including in
relationships. Yeah, I was saying that a
lot of men now they want princess
treatment. Girls, when you're watching
this, you know exactly what I mean. It
is true. Yeah, but I think it's a
mentality. You got to think um I
remember I was speaking with a friend of
mine. He's a sort of like a grandfather
for me. He's older and we always have
debates about life and society and he
said that when he grew up
yeah, if he would like a girl his his
father would tell him, "You need to
think how you are going to build a house
so you can raise a family with her." And
I don't think we teach that this
generation and a more it doesn't just
mean for men also for women that there
are ideas that they need to have this
free kind of relationships without any
commitment. How do we restore that
because I think when you restore that
then you will go back to traditional
gender roles?
Yeah, yeah and and
I marvel at no end when I hear for
example women all the time complaining
about men
you know and I can't find a good man to
marry and and this and that but then you
find out there every boyfriend they're
sleeping with and it's kind of like you
know there's there's a saying which is
kind of like if you get why buy the cow
if you get the milk for free.
I know it's a very unflattering but it's
very popular in America and you know so
I guess
to a good extent I think women are more
responsible or
because it's them they need to hold
because men are going to want it men are
going to chase it right? We know that so
you know women should not succumb to
that and for their own good for their
own virtue and for their own future as
because they when they do you know if
the man already got it there's a good
chance he why should he pay for it now?
You see what I'm saying so
I'm not trying to exonerate men at all.
I'm just simply saying women should at
least guard themselves because the men
you know they want what they want so To
wrap it up
this beautiful book I think it deserves
even more attention it is already a best
seller. If you would say there's one
lesson people can take away from it what
is it?
That because this book deals
specifically with Christian Europeans
that a Christian man need not be an
oxymoron. Today a Christian man to me is
an oxymoron because if you're
an oxymoron meaning the two words do not
work together. You can't be a man and a
Christian or a Christian and a man
according to today's standards but what
I'm saying is no you can be you can
truly be fully 100% man and fully 100%
Christian.
It sounds like I'm getting into some
Christology here but okay. So that's
what these men prove because they were
very religious, very hardcore about
their faith and they were had no problem
with violence, masculinity, what we
would call toxic masculinity. No one
understood what that meant, okay?
Um so, I think that's the grand lesson
which I think is very refreshing to a
lot of young men especially who want to
be Christians but are just tired of
feeling that to be a Christian I have to
act like a woman and sit and cry and and
never resist evil and and find Islam
appealing because Okay, no, you can stay
within your own tradition and it's all
there but in even nobler form.
I think this is such an important
message. I really hope it will be more
promoted. We need to give it more
attention as humans beings as well
because I think a big thing about the
manosphere for example or even a woke
ideology is that it's been pushed by
algorithm. So, the way people think,
they receive the world doesn't just go
through the education but online has
been paying a big uh Mhm. big role in
that. So, I hope when you're watching
this, you like and you share it and
thank you so much for watching and thank
you for the interview. Thanks, Scarlet.
Good to talk with you. Bring back
the fire.
Bring back
the flame.
the fire
in the righteous
name.